whether any I was going to ask you this
at the end but I'm gonna ask you now and
whether any chapters that you could have
considered adding that you didn't I said
that's a very good question there there
were two that I could have done that I
didn't okay one one was Green okay which
I have been becoming more and more
interested in and I think there's
whatever people's views about the about
the nature of climate change the best
way to deal with it and so on is it's
clear there is at this point an element
of crowd mentality that's kicking in and
I suppose the other one that was that
where I could have done I thought about
doing but decide to put off to another
day was mental health because I think
that mental health in general is a
fascinating fascinating issues it's come
very fast into the mainstream and I
think we know good in all sorts of ways
but there are lots of issues around
mental health that I'm very skeptical
about not that you know do need to get
into all of them but I I don't entirely
share a lot of the presumptions of the
age and I think that it basically it has
some of the same absolutes of the things
I'm discussing here is that you get on
to the thing and you don't know where to
correct or it becomes almost impossible
to say stop at any point
and I tell you I mean with the mental
health one just not bang on but one the
ones I noticed a few years ago was that
there were certain mental illnesses that
people clearly wanted to have and ones
they did it well okay so you just
invited me to jump in paid highly few
atomic bomb but I were here we go
let's dessert I noticed for instance
speaking to doctor friends and everyone
that bipolar this isn't to say that
there aren't people who are bipolar but
that it was a good thing some people
thought to have diagnosed similar to OCD
right and and what's striking to me is
that there are mental health afflictions
that are just definitely not the ones
that people would want and they are
under diagnosed by comparison so
schizophrenia but nobody thinks it's
cool to be schizophrenic
and right whereas on a date somebody's
saying and I you know have bipolar
issues it's not that everyone loves that
but there'll be some people who'll be
like you know that that's whereas if you
say no by the way I should tell you I'm
a schizophrenic hmm it has a different
it's the branding right it's it's people
talk about hum OCD but I'm really only
OCD in the kitchen you know I've got
mental health as if as if there's some
kind of calling card yeah
anyhow so yeah I could have done that
but I decided to put that off another
day and it's just there's entire book
just like that
[Music]
you